oh my god you can't even do what you
want
there was a time early on in the
twilight franchise that kristen stewart
and robert pattinson were forbidden to
be lovers
from being forced to miss significant
life events to being fired over a small
breach of contract the cast of twilight
had to follow all sorts of strict rules
in order to stay with the franchise
which broken rule resulted in a
different actress playing victoria in
the third film
it's my birthday right now
the team behind twilight really
considered having pattinson take on the
role of edward cullen after he did an
audition with kristen stewart where the
chemistry could not be ignored the
electricity between the actors was in
fact a bit too good it was so spicy that
director catherine hardwick had to
remind the actors that the movie reading
was pg-13 sure there were no sticky
situations pattinson was told he had to
keep his distance from his co-star
especially because she was underage at
the time that they met we all know they
didn't stay apart for too long though
there was immediate chemistry between
the two of you
yeah yeah
one rule kristen stewart wasn't a fan of
at all was having to wear uncomfortable
and visually limiting colored contacts
it was really difficult for the actress
to focus while performing since she was
having a tough time seeing but
ultimately she didn't have a choice in
the matter stewart wasn't the only one
though
loads of twilight actors had to endure
the same requirement and none of them
enjoyed it
doing the twilight films was a full-time
commitment which resulted in actors
having to miss some pretty significant
life events to be on set instead kristen
stewart was forced to skip her own high
school graduation ceremony
the filming of bella's grad scene
happened to coincide with stewart's
actual graduation
so instead of ignoring her own milestone
completely the actress had a mini
ceremony on set an extra was set to
shake stewart's hand while she wore the
cap and gown diploma in hand all for a
mock photo
at least she has a picture even if it is
fake this isn't the time to make hard
and fast decisions this is the time to
make mistakes
ever wonder why richelle lefeve aka
victoria in the first two twilight films
was replaced the actress wound up
breaking a pretty important rule and
lost her spot in twilight because of it
the actress had signed on to do 10 days
on a movie called barney's version which
wound up conflicting with the twilight
schedule while the actress's contract
did allow her to do other short projects
the production company felt they hadn't
been given enough notice the team wasn't
able to change the filming schedule to
accommodate her by that point so the
actress was replaced by bryce dallas
howard
well the circumstances around it had
nothing to do with us the bella actress
definitely had a rough go on set some
days especially when she was made to
wear excruciating hair extensions
while it may have looked good on screen
stuart wasn't a fan at all not being
able to refuse the extensions left
stuart with some bad memories after
seeing a photo of herself in the film
her initial thought is really
uncomfortable hair extensions for his
role as the dreamy vampire robert
pattinson had to learn how to drive
that's right the actor didn't actually
have a license and he needed to be
certified before he could film the
driving scenes the whole ordeal was
really rushed and he wound up taking
some crash course driving lessons in
oregon where filming was taking place to
get that needed license the rules nikki
reed had to follow wound up having to
change in the middle of the franchise
the actress had to bleach her hair and
scalp so she could turn her brunette
locks blonde but the damage was so
intense she began losing chunks of hair
this was the point that the hair dying
rule was dropped and luckily reed's
suffering ended when she started wearing
a wig from new moon onwards
it's not like i got to pick out my legs
no my hair color changed all the time
being part of such a major franchise the
cast had to deal with some very intense
fans
the twyhearts
in the name of good press and making
sure the saga continued to be successful
the actors had to entertain fans and
make sure to put their best foot forward
even though they may not have understood
the obsession themselves people
recognizing it as the most bizarre
thing
pattinson went a step further and
actually had dinner with a fan that had
been stalking him in spain however it
wasn't exactly the dream date she was
hoping for the actor made for a terrible
date complaining about everything he
could and pattinson never saw or heard
from the fan again
very exciting
when new moon was first announced taylor
lautner's name was nowhere to be seen as
the team wasn't sure he'd suit the role
anymore the actor was meant to be bigger
in new moon and the team wanted to stay
faithful to the books but unfortunately
for lautner he wasn't where they needed
him to be physically until the jacob
actor took matters into his own hands
lautner went on a hardcore bulking
mission eating every two hours and
working out at least two hours five days
a week in order to gain an impressive 30
pounds
the biggest thing i learned is that it's
just as hard to maintain as it was to
put on in the in the first place
it didn't matter if the actors were
uncomfortable filming took place in two
locations that can get very cold oregon
and canada the actors had no choice but
to endure the frighteningly low
temperatures and freezing rain
a couple days working in bad weather
might not be so bad but the twilight
actors went through this nightmarish
filming experience for a full four weeks
very early on in the process
luckily filming got a bit easier for the
performers as things went on
uh we're getting pneumonia that's what
we're doing adhering to rules and
requirements for christian steward and
robert pattinson started even before the
actors secured their roles the two had
to show off their electric chemistry
together for director catherine hardwick
by getting very intimate and kissing on
her bed since they didn't officially
have the jobs yet the actors dove right
in and even wound up going a bit too far
for the camera this was one rule they
definitely didn't mind following
robert pattinson brought his broody
vibes to the set when filming but the
producers were not feeling them
pattinson was instructed to tone down
the intense and moody vampire vibes
the producers even went so far as to
highlight every time the character
smiles in the books to prove to him just
how much happier he could be
but the actor wasn't going to let it go
without a fight i got a different color
highlighter and highlighted all the time
when he frowns and kind of things like
that
though ultimately the production wasn't
there to play games so they gave him an
ultimatum i came back to lunch was like
hi
i'm
there was definitely a lot of fantasy in
the twilight series but some story lines
were confusing for the actors and even
if they didn't agree with the action
they had to stick to it and perform
kristen stewart was particularly put off
with the way bella was portrayed once
she became a vampire they just kind of
they just want to bone it's the most
ridiculous
pattinson hasn't been so subtle about
his distaste for the series either when
i read it it seemed like it wasn't it
was like it was a book that wasn't
supposed to be published in this case
we're on the actor's side performing
ridiculous story lines is definitely a
tough rule to have to follow
taylor lautner didn't have a very easy
time on set while he did work extremely
hard to attain his peak physique he
didn't anticipate just how much he'd
have to be shirtless for the movies
it was an embarrassing and awkward
position to be in but the actor had no
choice as it kept being written into the
script and highlighted with other lines
isn't he on a shirt
looking back to his harry potter days
cedric diggory had considerably bushier
eyebrows than edward cullen the actor
had to get his eyebrows plucked and
tamed so he looked like the slick
vampire he was meant to be at least for
the first two movies the actor wasn't a
fan of the look and by the time eclipse
came out he got to grow out his brows a
bit rocking a scruffier vibe being part
of such a major franchise isn't an easy
job
but despite some strict rules and
intense requirements the actors totally
pulled off their roles it's hard to
believe they weren't always big fans of
the storylines with such convincing
performances which rule do you think was
most intense